the anterior cruciate ligament or makes
the y is one of the
four main ligaments that
connects the femur to the tibia the ac
provides stability when you
move your knee an
ac l tear can occur if the ankle joint
your knee is over-broken or if you receive
a direct blow to the front
of your knee if it
tears completely your doctor may
recommend surgery to repair it
before the procedure you will receive
spinal anesthesia which numbs your
body from the chest down  the
lower part or general anesthesia which will
keep you asleep during the
procedure during the
arthroscopic procedure the surgeon will make a few
small incisions around the
knee through which he will insert
surgical instruments and even a
camera the camera will transmit images to
a tv monitor the  that the surgeon
will see during the procedure
first the surgeon will remove the remaining parts
before you tear the ac l of your
knee
and then remove apart of the
patellar tendon to use as a graft or
obtain donor tissue the surgeon
will create attachment points for the graft
by drilling a small
tunnel in the end of the tibia and then
another in  the end of the femur the surgeon
will place one end of the
patellar tendon graft in the tibial tunnel
then lift the graft through
the knee joint and into the
femoral tunnel to create a new tendon
lastly the surgeon will place small
screws in  the tunnels at each end
of the new bone graft to hold it in
place for the next 6 to 8 weeks
bone growth will fill in these
tunnels and stabilize the graft
at the end of the procedure the doctor
will remove the instruments and close the
incisions  two to two
and a half hours after the procedure you
will go to the recovery room for
two to  three hours and then
go home you will probably
need a knee brace and
crutches for one to four weeks
supervised physical treatment will begin
two to three days after surgery and
continue for six to ten weeks
after this time continue
self-directed treatment on  time
it takes a reconstructed CL takes
approximately nine months to heal
completely you should avoid
racquet contact sports and other sports that
require quick changes of direction
until you get your doctor's approval